I've started writing a play when it's
finished I want the two of you to play
the leading roles and what should you
call it master watchmakers son welcome
back everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my watchman episode 1 video there's
all kinds of comic book Easter eggs this
is meant to be a sequel series to the
comic book not the movie so we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing an HBO now giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Watchmen moment on the video careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet will do top 10 WTF and
easter eggs starting with number 10 the
flashback to the riots so this is
actually a real event happening in 1921
but there's a lot of plays within plays
stories within stories they're doing a
very tales of the black freighter within
the series where characters are watching
stories or listening stories or reading
stories about the story within the story
so it gets really meta if you didn't
read the original comic series or you
haven't seen the movie tales of the
black freighter which is an in-universe
comic book story that told the story of
what was happening in the actual
Watchmen story only with old-timey
pirates if you're not familiar with this
in real world history this actually
happened it was basically 1921 just this
giant massacre of all these people it
was really terrible but they do a really
good job of connecting it to what's
happening in present day as well as some
of the characters in present day through
Lou Gossett Jr's character number 9 you
transitioned to present-day Tulsa
Oklahoma on that same road where Lou
Gossett jr. as a little boy crashed the
cop gets taken down by the cavalry
member sort of setting off the action of
the episode and they want you to believe
that the cavalry has been dormant for a
long time and they've come back and
there's the big villain that everybody
needs to take down but we don't really
find out till the end of the episode
that they're really only a small part of
this grand conspiracy as Lou Gossett
Jr's character teases but obviously the
next big easter egg is the Rorschach
mask they spend a lot of time during
this opening scene kind of letting you
know what the rules are in present day
so the cops actually can't unlock their
guns unless a dispatcher does it back
bays but there's all kinds of modern
technology that they've derived from dr.
Manhattan so if it wasn't clear you see
all these cars driving around like even
Angela or sister Knight whatever you
want to call her drives around in an old
school looking muscle car but it's
electric all their cars are electric
based on the science that they were able
to derive from dr. Manhattan by studying
his abilities the soundtrack was amazing
we get our first cues for the Nine Inch
Nails music Atticus Ross and Trent
Reznor are doing the music for the
series the cool thing is is they
actually found out that HBO was making a
watchman series and reached out to HBO
to try and do the music for before HBO
reached out to them number eight you go
to present-day you see Angela teaching
them how to bake cookies there's a lot
of Easter eggs in this scene - they also
convey a lot of history through her
exposition so there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs there's a dr. Manhattan
stream on national television that's
running 24/7 he's on Mars constructing
and destroying things while she's
talking about the exact same thing it's
a big metaphor for what's happening with
dr. Manhattan right now so it's clear
that he's back at least in relative
proximity to earth he's not in a
different galaxy because at the end of
the original comic series and at the end
of the movie he implied that he was
leaving to go to a different part of the
universe but at some point I guess it's
implied that he came back and he's
basically next door just a couple
planets away when she's making the moon
cakes when she cracks the eggs it turns
into the watchman's smiley face with a
little blood spatter they gave you a
little history lesson on the Vietnam War
the reason why it's a state is because
of what dr. Manhattan did during the
Vietnam War with a comedian they make a
reference to Robert Redford being
president you see him in the background
here he's been president for the last
thirty plus years ever since Nixon and
we find that they put Nixon on Mount
Rushmore right next to Lincoln they also
reference something called red for
Dacians which is basically reparations
from Robert Redford and I think that has
something to do with the white knight
that they reference so number seven the
white knight they don't completely
explain it but I felt like they give you
enough to know what happened and it's
supposed to be the last major attack
that the cavalry perpetrated on all the
law-enforcement agents which is the
basis for why they all wear masks now
they make a reference to not paying
taxes later during the interrogation I
also believe that people who were part
of that don't have to pay taxes anymore
- as part of those redford ations know
six is raining squids so a siren goes
off while they're driving down the
street and it immediately just starts
hailing down all these tiny squids if
it's no big deal like it's been going on
for a long time they even have a special
cleanup crew like you have the
garbageman that come around picking up
people's trash cleaning up all the
squids there's even a little symbol on
the back of this truck we don't know why
that's happening but they make a
reference to a transdimensional attack
conspiracy so I think that has something
to do with Ozymandias but they don't
completely reveal that there were a lot
of Ozymandias references to the original
series at the end of the episode that
I'll get to and one of those was to the
squid that he teleported into New York
at the end of the comic series pretty
safe bet that these tiny squid that are
hailing down have something to do with
that one of the squids when it rains
down is the kids looking at it even
mushas up to look kind of like a
Rorschach inkblot they were also a lot
of Rorschach references when they were
interrogating that prisoner - but number
5 the American hero story TV show that's
another tales of the black freighter
type of device the way they're using it
a show within the show commenting on
what the actual TV show is about but
it's basically meant to be a TV show
about The Adventures of the original
Minutemen because you remember that in
history Watchmen actually happens so dr.
Manhattan was around all the events of
the original movie in many years before
that The Adventures of the Minutemen
there's a reference on Lou Gossett Jr's
newspaper that Adrian vite is dead
that's awesome man Diaz so the world
believes that he's dead which we know is
not true because he totally shows up at
the end of the episode over in Wales we
hear the Cavalry's manifesto it's not
clear what their mission is they don't
find out what their mission is by the
end of the episode they only know that
they were doing something with really
old-school batteries old-school watch
batteries that is no surprise watches
are very important to Watchmen the idea
of the watch itself but also the
Doomsday Clock there were several
references to that like their big chant
is tick tock which is a literal
reference to the Doomsday Clock of the
original series but the Doomsday Clock
itself is actually a real-world thing is
sort of the countdown to nuclear
annihilation like during the Cold War
how close were we to actually firing
missiles on Russia and how close were
they to firing missiles on us a lot of
that gets into the idea of the grander
conspiracy that they teased during the
episode and that also sort of dovetails
with what's going on with Ozymandias at
the end he says I'm writing
new play that'll become more clear in
the next couple of episodes the
translation on the Latin phrase that
they all chant isn't quite perfect but
it has something to do with the guards
who guard themselves when we go into Don
Johnson's office she's sitting there
drinking from an owl mug another night
owl reference
there's a giant police spec owl ship
later in the episode all kinds of night
owl references there's a lots of owls
hooting through the episode you actually
hear real owls in the middle of the
night I think the significance of the
mug though is just to the original night
owl who used to be a police officer
before he took up the name night owl and
became a vigilante number for the
interrogation so they throw the suspect
into what they're calling the pod and
you get to see what Looking Glass does
he doesn't have any special powers he
just really good at interrogating people
and this is meant to be a sophisticated
version of a Rorschach inkblot test they
eventually beat the information about
the ranch out of him but their home base
so number three the Battle of the cattle
ranch a literal cattle ranch but also
their secret hideout they don't really
make it clear how big their group is but
they're obviously called the seventh
Cavalry that's actually a reference to
Custer Little Bighorn like she gets the
pager call with the message that says
Little Bighorn
that was where Custer died at the Battle
of Little Bighorn apparently they don't
care about collateral damage because
they mow through all their own cattle to
get at the police but probably my
favorite moment from this big fight
scene was the reveal of the our ship is
revealed that Don Johnson and his
co-pilot who's actually named pirate
Jenny which is also a reference to the
song pirate Jenny which was used during
the Watchmen movie and is also an
important idea of the Watchmen comic
book series they're in a version of an
alo ship that looks like it was spectate
for police use like maybe niteowl to
sold his technology to the government or
to the police force because it seems
like they built a brand-new version it's
not the original allo ship it's just
another law enforcement vehicle that
probably other police departments all
over the country have they never quite
figure out what the batteries are for
that they were trying to escape with but
that will probably come back around in
the next couple of episodes number two
speaking of coming back around welcome
back Ozymandias so if it wasn't clear
from all the Easter eggs and
foreshadowing Jeremy Irons is playing
the older version of Ozymandias that
apparently the world thinks is dead
they shot all of his scenes in Wales
which I believe is where this is meant
to be so he has this vast country estate
in whale
and he's just been hiding out this whole
time bleeping this really weird
eccentric life apparently clothes are
optional like he says it's a big deal
that he's putting clothes on I felt like
it was pretty clear the anniversary that
they were referring to even if you
didn't read the original comic series
they're referring to the original event
at the end of the comic series where he
teleported a giant squid into New York
City to make people believe that there
was an alien attack a transdimensional
attack which they also kind of
referenced during the interrogation
earlier you see the play that he's
writing he talks about it later he calls
it the watchmakers son which is
obviously a reference to dr. Manhattan
who is literally the son of a watchmaker
when he says a tragedy in five acts
that's gonna be broken up through five
acts of the TV show over the course of
nine episodes the cake is yellow
designed to look like his classic
Watchmen comic book costume but also the
pattern of the icing is made to look
like the squid draped over the top right
now he is kind of giving off a villian
vibe which is kind of the way he came
off during the original series but just
like he was in the original comic series
he isn't necessarily an evil person he's
trying to advance the cause of humanity
but he's doing it like he says through
fear so that might have something to do
with it raining squids on everyone all
the time and this growing conflict with
the 7th cavalry in the Oklahoma Police
the watch that they give him as a gift
is the watch from the original Watchmen
comic-book series that's why it seems
like he's triggered a little bit when he
sees it like he's surprised he's a
little bit of a flashback you know
obviously number one WTF was the ending
of the episode where sister night finds
Lou Gossett jr. claiming to have hung up
Don Johnson's character but it's pretty
clear that she doesn't believe that he
did the job but they also don't believe
that the seventh Cavalry was responsible
so somebody else is messing with them
here in Don Johnson's character that
also will probably dovetail with
Ozymandias his brand new plan overall it
was a great setup there's a lot of
bigger stuff in play here like they make
it seem like this is all about the
police versus the cavalry but then they
blow that up at the end of the episode
by making it seem like it's a way way
bigger thing going on so if you spotted
any big Easter eggs during the episode
that I didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments and let
me know what your favorite part was I'll
wait to see how everyone feels about the
series after this first episode and how
this video does before I plan a whole
bunch
Watchmen videos but if you guys like it
in the video does well I will do all the
episodes the Mandalorians Star Wars
series is also starting in a couple
weeks to Rick and Morty is coming back
there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up
including The Witcher Netflix series
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
my next watchman video everybody click
here to watch that Star Wars Episode
nine teaser trailer and click here for
that Game of Thrones prequel teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight